hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this one i'll be
giving you a little video on a very
popular website and you've probably used
it sometime in your life and that is
google.com so as you can see by the
title there's another way to use
google.com so for this example i'm going
to give you a very basic tutorial on how
to use the new google interface and it
is actually really impressive and
actually has a noticeable speed
difference
so right here on the regular google.com
it's it's dark blue text it does have
the light buttons and you can go to more
and expand this and check this out
in the middle you can obviously make
your search so for my example i'm going
to search android and you can hit google
search as you can see it loaded all 63
million results for android in about
0.31 seconds
the web images and video filters all
remain at the top
so if we want to have another way to use
google here's something you can go to
the description of this video and paste
this code
that i have in the description
javascript code hit enter
then open google.com in a new video or a
new window or a new tab and you'll be
directed to the new google.com interface
this is something that google's been
testing for a little bit and it is
really cool
so now you can see the google search
button is blue and i'm feeling lucky is
also blue and this up here is a little
bit lighter blue but that's not the only
cool thing watch as i type in the middle
android we get the same suggestions
i'll google search that and notice on
the left hand side we have a much much
more extensive uh custom sort of filter
for our search content so we can search
everything images and video all in the
left hand side and also see also related
topics and this is going to be something
very helpful
also you might have noticed it's it's
quite a bit faster on the right hand
side the same amount of results loaded
in 0.22 seconds so you can click on
advanced search here and and click on a
number of different things these options
have always been available with
google.com but i think this right here
is going to be the most impressive part
of the new google interface so go ahead
and take a look around in it you know
tell me what your thoughts are in the
comments section if you have any
thoughts or questions about how to use
this or what to use it for feel free to
drop a line in the description
or in the comments section of this video
so thank you for watching and i hope you
enjoy the new google.com and leave your
thoughts in the description or in the
comments section i'm sorry so thank you
for watching guys peace